Hi, my name is Alex Taylor.
And I'm Amy Mitano, and today we're in...
...Spain.
This is Madrid, my uncle and aunt live in Madrid.
Really?
Uh-huh.
Madrid is a big city and it's really fun.
Great food, great music.
Amy, what's that?
It's the royal palace.
Wow! That's a big building.
And this is Barcelona.
Barcelona is my favorite city in Spain.
It has a lot of great buildings.
Hey, what's that?
It's called "Sagrada Familia", it's my favorite building in Barcelona.
Where are those people?
In a restaurant.
Oh, I love Spanish food.
Now, we're in Andalucia.
This is flamenco.
Flamenco is music and it's dancing.
Hey, is that a guitar?
Uh-huh, it is.
And that's my uncle, he makes guitars.
Cool.
And this is a flamenco singer.
Now, we're in Granada.
Wow! Those buildings are amazing.
And this is Cordoba, it's in the south of Spain.
Hmmm, it's beautiful.
Well, those are some of my favorite places in Spain.
Yeah, it's an amazing country.